all right Herbie help me out here if
Alabama and Ohio State were that close
going into this weekend according to the
committee
then how did Ohio State not move up a
little bit and Alabama go down since one
plate and one didn't I don't necessarily
think that there's equation or any
anything that you can point to as far as
evidence I think I'm an example of what
the committee ended up doing I I said on
gameday Saturday morning JCCC
championship when we got into this
discussion
these what-if scenarios and we said what
if this favorite scenario plays out
what if Ohio State beats Wisconsin and
who's gonna be in that four spot and I
said based on Ohio State's resume they
would be Big Ten champs and they'd have
three wins over Alabama I thought Ohio
State would happy yet then then I
watched the Ohio State Wisconsin game
and I don't know if the committee looked
at it the way I did absolutely do you
asking me if the goal is to put the best
four teams in III said Alabama after
watching the Big Ten championship
despite them winning the game I felt
that Alabama should be the team they
should go again I don't know what the
committee looks at I know there are
coaches on that committee I gotta
believe that at the end of the day when
you watch 12 or 13 weeks of college
football I personally believe the best
four teams are in the playoffs how they
got there I leave it up to everybody to
speculate because it's subjective but I
also look at the conference title game
and I don't know the value of it Herbie
I you know USC to me should have been in
where Wisconsin is now I want to see
what you've done in the last couple of
weeks Alabama hasn't looked impressive
Ohio State you can't get rid of the Iowa
loss where everybody understands that
they did go out and play a tough
schedule they played Oklahoma they lost
to Oklahoma I understand all of those
things but by the end of the year
Alabama did not distinguish themselves
as a great team we know they're a great
brand I thought that these other schools
that played for a conference
championship won a conference
championship at least it played well in
the latter part of this season your
thoughts
and I'm not trying to take away from
when oh hi oh stay in USC did this year
I mean your goal when you get together
in August every conference is to win a
championship you know and Ohio State
they get rings they hit their picture
put up in the Woody Hayes facility the
same could be said for USC
so what they accomplished is great again
all I can do by it I agree with what
Alabama gets Mississippi State and all
but was necessarily their breath that's
brand of football and they would tell
you that a lot of the injuries started
to mount up especially in the defensive
side of the ball
III would tell you by the time these
teams all get together in late December
and early January I would challenge you
to watch Alabama and watch how they play
against Clemson and tell me they're not
one of the best four teams I it's just
listen I'm gonna lie what do I say I was
a captain there anybody wants to pull
out the pom-poms and say Ohio State
should be there you would think it would
be me I've always for 22 years said what
I think for better or worse and I'm just
telling you after watching all these
teams play Alabama is better than USC I
don't say what the numbers show I don't
care what conference championships are
playing in Alabama is a better team so
if the goal of the committee they don't
have to necessarily have answers for why
they're putting teams in the top four
they don't have to look at this team or
this game this team lost that game
you've got coaches that evaluate game
films and they're gonna look at the same
thing I'm looking at they're going to
tell you that Alabama is just a better
team and end of the day they don't have
to have reasons if Ohio State went out
and beat Wisconsin the way they did in
2014 when they were in question that
year TCU and Baylor were the odds on
favorites to get in that year and Ohio
State leapfrog both of those teams into
the top four they would win the national
championship if you'll notice they put
59 did nothing other than Meyer was on
top of mountains that night telling
everybody in the world you and Baylor
nothing Meyer wasn't on top of mountains
this time yelling about how his team
should be in and when Overmeyer got the
news over Meyer wasn't beating on top of
a table saying how dare they lead my
team out Urban Meyer I think deep down
knows his team's probably not ready for
what they would have seen if they took
Quinn's initiative to me the best for
got in we can argue about it we can
discuss how they came to this the end of
the day it's just a fact about who are
the best teams I personally look at it
and say the committee has some serious
stones I guess you could say support the
SP champion an ACC champion leave out
the Big Ten champ in another SEC champ
and the big 12 champion gets in with
Oklahoma the easy way the politically
correct way would have been to put Ohio
State in and kind of check all the boxes
no harm no foul instead I think people
should be applauding that they were
willing to do this because next year it
might be your team that's in this
scenario it might be your conference
it's in this scenario so I applaud what
they did it took a lot of courage and
guts to do it and like I said at the end
of the day in my opinion they have the
best four teams on he's Kirk Herbstreit
from the mothership College GameDay will
be in Philadelphia it's Army versus Navy
all right a couple other items
who's gonna coach 10 somebody has to
coach Tennessee so who's going to get
the job I think the most important thing
how crazy of a week was that for
Tennessee and for their fan base most
important thing gonna happen is they put
one of their own on top of this
leadership in Phillip Fulmer a guy that
accomplished a great deal as a coach was
there as a player and I think if
anything it just settles down the noise
instead of they've had leadership from
everywhere else except Tennessee and I
think that is an important hire and now
they can kind of go about how they're
going to come up with what to avenge
that should be their head coach and now
that quiet yeah I mean they're from
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday it was
like people reporting planes or going
over to Stillwater planes are headed
over here to West Lafayette looking at
Jeff Brohm and looking at Gandhi oh no
now they're gonna over here to Dave
Turin
everybody knew everything now of a
sudden it's quiet and so I would not be
surprised to see a name surfaced and
nobody's talking about because I think
that with Phillip Fulmer in charge
they're doing a much better job of
keeping it quiet and trying to figure
out who's the best fit could Baker
Mayfield get every first-place vote for
the Heisman and one last thing on
Tennessee I'm sorry Dan I heard somebody
when I first came on saying that
Tennessee's not a great job I disagree
with that you could have said the same
thing about Alabama when Nick Saban got
there back in Oh 607 Alabama was not a
great job but look who showed up to make
it a great job if you find a great coach
with the history of Tennessee football
that orange P travels well in recruiting
maybe as well as any other brand in the
SEC you don't have to recruit just in
Tennessee in North Carolina and Georgia
that orange P will go into Texas it'll
go to California when they're really
going so if they make the right
selection you'll be funny in two or
three years to see how everybody will
see it Tennessee's a dumpster fire who
would want that job - wow that is a
top-ten job so it's very very important
they get this right because to me it
still can be a great job second thing on
Baker Mayfield its slam dunk people want
to try to talk about the Kansas game and
some of the incidents and things done
it's not going to be enough to hold
people back
I voted last night and you're sitting
there looking at one two and three very
very difficult to look at that ballot
and watch what Baker Mayfield's done
from week one only through the big 12
championship game and not put him at the
top of the board other guys have had
great years with rights love did it
Stanford's remarkable Lamar Jackson had
a bit of you this year individually than
he did a year ago so yeah great all the
candidates but today Baker Mayfield had
a incredible year one final thing if you
could and I'm looking at the language
here I think for the college playoff
committee this with the motherships TV
deal that the language they can't alter
the playoff Final Four it goes through
2026 does that sound right Herbie and if
you could change it right now and go to
six or eight you had the power to change
it right now would you
No so now I and depending on the years
you decide to pay for is right maybe two
is better this year or that year I like
for because I like I like the debate I
think it's healthy I think it's easy to
just say hey put five power five
conference teams and find three others
and everybody goes home happy I don't
think there's anything wrong with teams
being left out I I think unfortunately
there's such focus and I was born right
now Dan with college football in the
playoffs that this era of player
unfortunately is being left out USC gets
left out Ohio State gets left out others
get left out and it's almost like a
buzzkill it's like oh my gosh what a
letdown of the year we don't want a
conference championship and they're
going to play each other in a huge bowl
game and when you and I were kids it was
fun to watch these teams and these
intersectional matchups and ball games
and it was pride on the line and it was
a lot of fun to watch and I still feel
that way I think this generation of fan
is it doesn't feel that way because it's
all in or nothing and that to me is a
kind of a sad part of feel so I would
love to see people still put you know
some some importance and appreciation
for playing in these other bowl games
because for the kids I'm just telling
you you watch some of these bowl games
and we can poopoo them and all we want
for the players there's still a deal
when they get a chance to go and and
play in these and but I would keep it at
four right now I'm comfortable with that
and I'm comfortable with teams being
left out and being frustrated and trying
to get better the next year thanks
Herbie tell the boys we said hello have
fun in Philadelphia with Army and Navy
this weekend yeah and one last thing you
guys on Sunday night I've gotten so busy
over the years of college football and
Sunday football is hard for me to always
tune in and I go to some of the Titans
games and miss a lot of the games during
the day I've got into the habit of
watching you guys go to prison with all
the highlights and you guys analysis and
in the game itself you guys really set
the bar on Sunday night so keep up the
great work every postseason and great
holidays
thank you Herbie I appreciate them for
more Dan Patrick show too
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]